foreign
[Music]
up nearly 6 000 kilometers to an
altitude of nearly 6 000 kilometers
before falling down to Earth again
that's very similar to a trajectory for
another ICBM launch last November and
they reckoned that if you translate that
into distance traveled over the Earth's
surface that would put the continental
United States within range
thank you
what was interesting about the test was
that North Korea reports that the
decision to launch this was given
without warning to the launch Crews and
so this doesn't seem so much like it was
a test especially of the underlying
technology as it was a drill for the
launch Cruise
[Music]
foreign
they are describing this as a state-run
media from North Korea as what they call
a sudden launching drill they have in
recent tests been developing
um this uh technique whereby they deploy
set up a missile and fire it and launch
it fairly quickly by doing that you give
your adversaries less chance to detect
that you're launching a missile to try
to disrupt the missile launch or try to
intercept it
foreign
the message I think here is that North
Korea is not happy with the ramping up
of military exercises between the U.S
and South Korea which will take place in
March there's also a tabletop exercise
that will look at nuclear scenarios that
will happen between the U.S and South
Korea next week and I think North Korea
is sending a message that it is unhappy
with that and it will fight fire with
fire
[Music]